welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and obi-wan kenobi on disney plus
show obi-wan facing off with darth vader
for a second time but could obi-wan's
true conflict in the series actually be
with a world designed by a master
manipulator emperor shiv palpatine
everyone isn't just fighting the
inquisitor's invader my friends he is
fighting the culmination of sheave
schemes this is a new series we're
trying out here at new rockstars called
between the duels how everything from
star wars films tv series novels and
comics bridges the epic duel and revenge
of the sith to the rematch in obi-wan
kenobi on disney plus and in this video
we are going to explore how the sith's
thousand-year plan for vengeance makes
obi-wan's post-order 66 exile especially
cruel remember among the final words
exchanged between obi-wan and anakin and
their last duel and likely to come back
up in this obi-wan kenobi series
hopefully was you and the chosen one it
was said that you would destroy this and
not join them but the truth is anakin
skywalker was the chosen one only he was
actually chosen by the other side of a
sith revenge plot against the jedi a
thousand years in the making back in the
year 1032 bby a war between the jedi and
the sith came to an end with the defeat
of the sith on the planet rusan the sith
were mostly destroyed by infighting
among themselves leaving one survivor
darth bane bane created the sith rule of
two in which there would only ever be
two sith at any given time a master who
held the power of the dark side and an
apprentice who craved it until that
apprentice would kill their master and
take their place more importantly fewer
numbers meant the sith could exact
vengeance on the jedi from the shadows a
plan that would ultimately culminate in
darth sidious better known as shiv
palpatine who rudely talked over an
opera to talk about his rule of two in
the third person darth plagueis
the dark lord of the sith
so powerful and so wise
he could even keep the ones he cared
about
from dying
unfortunately
he taught his apprentice everything he
knew
then his apprentice killed him in his
sleep ironic you're giving your future
sith apprentice this same idea
unaware of the sith's survival the jedi
had become complacent and dogmatic
throughout the high republic era shaping
the world view of obi-wan kenobi and his
era of the jedi high council making
obi-wan a stricter teacher to anakin
skywalker leaving that young romantic
vulnerable to palpatine's influence
palpatine of course was obsessed with
skywalker from the start sensing the
boy's strength in the force after all
his midichlorian count was off the
charts he even told the kid and you
young skywalker
we will watch your career with great
interest followed by some naboo victory
music in which john williams hit his
emperor theme if you listen closely
[Applause]
[Music]
now did palpatine know at that point
that anakin was the chosen one perhaps
because the amazing 2017 darth vader
comics by charles soul and decepticon
coley show vader experiencing mystical
visions including sidious's form
creeping over anakin's pregnant mother
shmee conjuring anakin in her womb now
whether or not that was the objective
truth or a vision by sidious or like
vader writing his own fanfiction
autobiography it all remained still
debated but meanwhile publicly palpatine
rose to power of course as a senator
from naboo corrupting the republic at
its core all the while his alter-ego
sidious goaded the trade federation into
an invasion of naboo engineering a
crisis from both sides to install
himself as supreme chancellor upon the
trade federation's defeat during the
events of phantom menace they rallied
into an alliance to the confederacy of
independent systems to wage war against
the republic meanwhile a familiar name
of jedi master saifo diaz had a forced
vision of this coming war and secretly
ordered a clone army from the kaminoans
now did palpatine give sifo diaz's
visions probably not because really only
upon discovery did palpatine then send
count dooku to off sipo diaz and take
over the operation hiring jango fett as
a clone template if palpatine knew from
the start he wouldn't have added that
many steps probably but then as we learn
in clone wars season six palpatine
actually ordered the kaminoans to
secretly install biochips into the
clone's brains so that as his grand army
of the republic was deployed at the end
of attack of the clones palpatine had a
direct backdoor into the clone troopers
minds that it could trigger them to turn
on their jedi commanders at the right
moment actually the jedi almost found
out about this but neither anakin nor
rex believed fives when he warned them
it's in here it's in all of us organic
chips built into our genetic code
to make us do whatever someone wants
even killed the jedi now at this time
anakin was already facing quite a few
doubts about the jedi order after his
longtime friend ahsoka tano was falsely
accused by the jedi high council for
bombing the jedi temple an act actually
committed by berashafi leading to ahsoka
leaving the order but the more immediate
wedge that palpatine was able to
capitalize on during the events of
revenge of the sith of course involved
anakin's secret marriage with padme
clone wars final season actually hinted
obi-wan might have been aware of a
hollow chat that was happening between
them i hope you at least told padme i
said hello yeah the guy loves his hellos
hello there now how much obi-wan knew is
up for debate was he protecting anakin
because of his past relationship to the
mandalorian princess of satine did he
know padme was pregnant there i mean
that's debatable because anakin clearly
didn't despite the obvious baby bump the
animators added and despite the scene
taking place before the events of
revenge of the sith when a bump list
natalie portman first dropped the news
to anakin after the battle of coruscant
now that battle opens the revenge of the
sith when obi-wan and anakin rescue
palpatine from general grievous and
count dooku clearly palpatine arranged
his own kidnapping and matthew stover's
excellent novelization of this film
conveys dooku's realization of
palpatine's orchestration as he looks up
into the eyes of anakin skywalker for
the final time count dooku knows that he
has been deceived not just today but for
many many years that he has never been
the true apprentice he has existed only
for this this to be the victim of anakin
skywalker's first cold-blooded murder
first but not he knows the last then the
blades cross at his throat uncrossed
like scissors snip and all of him
becomes nothing at all
now the runway was clear for palpatine
to begin courting anakin more
aggressively he exploited anakin's grief
over shmee's death and his ire with the
jedi council for denying him the rank of
master and then presented himself as an
empathetic father figure a twisted
father that again the vader comic
suggested he might have been from a
certain point of view and the jedi those
poor beautiful fools played right into
this by having anakin spy on the
chancellor making him more vulnerable to
a both sides or bad argument which
palpatine could slyly hint to anakin
over a series of one-on-ones while the
jedi were spread out across the galaxy
to end the clone wars conflicts that
sidious ordered the separatists to fight
to the bitter end anakin all the while
was suffering nightmare visions of padme
dying in childbirth and daddy palpy was
right there with plagueis pipe dreams to
save her palp was poised to reap the
benefits of darth bane's dream the sith
would gain power not by stealing it
which was their historical folly they
would instead gain power because they
would be given it so now with all the
pieces in place order 66 unfolds you
know how it went down mace windu moved
to arrest palpatine actually a hollow
huddle that we see from both sides in
revenge of the sith and from ahsoka's
point of view in clone wars season seven
palpatine quickly slays agency 10 and
kid fisto leaving mace to face him alone
mace nearly has the old sith cornered
but palpatine again uses anakin's fears
of losing padme to trick in again into
thinking he needs him and so anakin
disarms mace literally and now with
anakin drawing the first jedi upon jedi
blood palpatine pulls the trigger
execute order 66.
[Music]
[Music]
so on kashyyyk yoda survives in clone
wars season 7 we saw rex is able to
resist his biochip and escape along with
ahsoka and maul a few other jedi are
able to survive grogu of course whoever
helped grogu escape as well as cal
kestes and caleb doom luminar unduly all
of whom might appear or get referenced
in obi-wan kenobi especially since
rebels confirms luminara as one of the
grand inquisitor's prized captures
rebels also shows how in the aftermath
of the purge obi-wan snuck back into the
jedi temple to send out a very important
coded message this is master obi-wan
kenobi i regret to report that both our
jedi order and the republic have fallen
with the dark shadow of the empire
rising to take their place
this message is a warning and a reminder
for any surviving jedi
trust in the force this message sets the
stage for the dark era obi-wan kenobi
now takes place and without obi-wan's
message that save house would not exist
revenge of the sith depicted obi-wan and
anakin's showdown on mustafar but
perhaps the most fateful duel was yoda
versus palpatine on the senate floor
really a perfect metaphor for
palpatine's plan to destroy the republic
from within metaphor literalized there's
no need for senate desks when you are
the senate obi-wan finishes his duel on
the high ground but had palpatine not
succeeded against yoda he would not have
been able to rescue anakin's corpse from
that lava beach and anakin would have
been left to burn so no matter what the
results of obi-wan's conflicts his high
ground is a landscape already won by the
sith and controlled by palpatine so this
ain't just a sunny desert detox for a
hermit as he looks forward to a life of
black melons and great dragon
impressions until he gets to mentor the
kid destined to blow up the death star
no no no kenobi has no idea any of that
future awaits him all he knows right now
is a life on the run from his former
students the fear of making the same
mistake again and the shame of being
played by the most cunning and
bloodthirsty sith in history and as we
look ahead to all of this unfolding in
the obi-wan kenobi series we will next
turn to kenobi's relationship with darth
vader and how this series will reframe a
very important exchange in a new hope i
want to thank you for joining us for
chapter one of between the duels be sure
to subscribe to new rockstars follow me
on instagram and twitter at ea boss
follow me rockstars thank you for
watching and bye
[Music]
you